what a night though for D'Angelo and his
return after being sidelined for six
games let's hear what he had to say with
Lakers reporter Mike trudell
all right Delaware is a few years since
we did one of these that game certainly
looked like fun you look like you were
having some fun just describe all of the
emotions uh that you're playing out
there with tonight I mean I just want to
bring that element to our team obviously
we've been through some things a little
few ups a few trades a bunch of random
stuff that we can use as an excuse I
just want to bring that fun back to this
organization bring that laughing Factor
bring all of that and let it translate
onto the floor so simple as that could
you feel the energy coming back up from
the building as you guys made those
pushes and a lot of them a lot of the
runs cemented by pull up threes from you
tonight for sure shout out to everybody
on our team everybody played a major
role Austin Reeves is special Brewery
special then it Schroeder special like
all these guys are are coming in and
trying to make up for what Brian you
know what we're missing with him so our
whole team did a hell of a job of
contributing tonight so you get traded
to this team and right away you guys go
three in the ones in the games that you
play Then you spray in the ankle it's
been a couple weeks you come back have
this kind of performance as the team
continue used to rise to D'angelo just
put that all in perspective as you're
trying to look ahead of these next
couple weeks and make a push they lucky
I sprained my ankle simple as that I was
ready to go crazy great have fun with
this and embrace the challenge and
opportunities all the pressure whatever
y'all want to call I was ready to
embrace that unfortunately I went out
with the ankle thing but like I said
everybody stepped up and everybody held
it down
um A.D been holding it down for us
tonight we tried to hold it down for him
so returning the favor as a team is is
what it's about last one for you a lot
of new pieces on this team you guys are
trying to figure each other out on the
fly but it's already been working what
does that tell you and how does that
give you some level of confidence man if
we get one training camp under our belt
with this group the sky's the limit
with that being said we don't have a
training camp under our belt and Scott's
still the limit our guys are ready our
guys are hungry and as an organization
these fans are going to get us through a
lot of them yeah
these are these fans gonna get us
through a lot of it with their energy so
we're just ready to compete and ready to
return the favor for the organization